there i tell you my story about john  malkovich i was doing a movie with john  and uh i  had shot a commercial over the weekend  okay and i was kind of embarrassed  because john is one of the great  american actors and uh we were between  scenes and he you know he was like um  how was your weekend  and i was like oh well how was your  weekend yeah i was like well you know it  was good i mean i kind of  sold my soul and did a did a commercial  he goes  hmm and i said  have you ever  done a commercial and he goes  well  i've  done  hundreds of them  he goes and  you don't sell your soul you rent it  just him selling [ __ ] tide pods well  you know he probably you put the laundry  into the laundry machine